foreign
[Music]
this is sogcast number nine my name is
John Striker Meyer I'll be your host
today thank you for joining us
and in previous sawcast we've had
members that have run Recon missions
we've had helicopter Pilots we've had
people that talked about different
aspects of the war the Sikh award the
eight year seek award macly sog one of
the aspects we haven't talked about is
the air support specifically from what
we called fact or Covey or nails
and that is the Air Force with a Green
Beret and a helicopter or in an aircraft
that coordinated with the teams on the
ground
and the assets that would be called in
to support them on missions and today
I'm pleased to announce that we have
Mike Taylor with us today who had three
and a half years in one tour of Duty in
Southeast Asia with special forces and
the main reason the first reason of many
stories he has we want to talk about
some of the many missions that you flew
over 300 missions as a week we used to
call him the cubby Rider and an and and
we should also explain that we had
assets that were flown in Laos that
launched from South Vietnam and
supported the secret War but we also had
the secret part of the secret war in nkp
and uh
um you could talk a little bit about
start about nkp and then let's just get
into a couple of your more extraordinary
admissions that you had run as a cubby
Rider in launching out of nkp Mike
welcome to the show thank you I'm very
happy to be here uh particularly talk
about nakan PanAm indeed nkp
I wish I had violated security all those
years and kept a journal or notes
because that would be a good story to
get out to the public that's all of our
wishes right yeah but I didn't unlike
you and John plaster and people who
obviously kept notes who are writing
these wonderful books did a lot of
interviews
uh an accountant Thailand is a Royal
Thai Air Force Base
located in the northeast corner of
Thailand right on the Mekong River
so as close to the prairie fire area of
operations as you could get in Thailand
and the reason it was important to
operate out of there there's two Monsoon
Seasons that are separated by the
animite mountains that run down through
Laos right so uh when it was the
Northeast Monsoon
fubai and concrete and most of the
typical launch sites in Vietnam the
weather would be unworkable
but the weather in the area of
operations and to the West over to
Thailand was workable
so I don't know what year
mid 60s to later 60s they got permission
most of the Royal Thai Air Force bases
were totally consumed by the U.S Air
Force we occupied their bases and
operated out of there it looked like a
U.S base but it was a Thai base and we
got permission to establish a launch
site as they were called
at nkp
so we had a small secure compound within
the larger Air Base
with a h-shaped building
um
we controlled access into the Cyclone
Fence nobody could get in unless we said
okay and then once you got in you could
only see the the front two legs of the H
in the crossbar and that was our living
quarters
and the supply room in the bar and the
mess hall but that if you drove around
back and went into the upper arms of the
H
that was the Tactical operations center
and the isolation area for the teams I
remember it quite well oh yeah
spent a little time there yeah so we had
a 13-man
Special Forces Detachment there
commanded by a major
two captains
ten enlisted guys an Ops guy an Intel
guy
and we call them a fact writer Ford air
controllers would go out and support the
teams
and we would put an experienced Recon
man in the back seat and we called him
fact Rider their call sign in Vietnam
was Covey so everybody in Vietnam and
I'm sure all day this morning you'll be
saying Covey Rider and that's fine we
don't take any offense
but the covey's was the call sign for
the 20th Tactical Air Support Squadron
out of Vietnam we were supported by the
23rd Tactical Air Support Squadron nail
call sign but we weren't nail writers we
were fact writers indeed yeah so
um we had huge giant Air Force
helicopters to transport the teams as
opposed to the king bees and Huey's that
they had in Vietnam
and uh helicopter gunships and cobras
and so forth didn't have the legs so we
were
thank God
escorted by the a1e skyraiders
a
World War II vintage you could say they
came out at the end of World War II they
didn't participate in World War II but
that was their vintage they made their
name in Korea
but they really made their name for us
indeed they could carry their own weight
in ordinance sure they could stay
forever
they could fly so slow you could knock
them out of there with a fly swatter
but what that meant was they were deadly
accurate
when you were trying to use f4s or
something like that you couldn't drop
close to the team
unless they were ready to die and say
drop it on me right but the enemy had a
tactic when the Tactical Air Support
showed up they call it getting close to
the Belt they wanted to Nestle up to
that team
so they couldn't get bombed well when
the a1s were there the spads
you could nestled up to my belt and they
could still bomb you and that hit me
yeah so every day we got two Ford air
controllers
that could regenerate the first sortie
that went out so that guy would fly the
first and the third sortie and the
second guy would take one in the middle
and that way we could cover the teams
all daylight hours
and uh we had one guy on the team that
was a fact writer that was his position
and he would fly the first and the third
and then usually I would take the second
one but there were other guys Gary Robb
and other people that wanted to fly as
well so I would like to let them fly
sometime if it was a boring day indeed
um and then when I first got there we
had the ch3 Air Force helicopter which
was called the Jolly Green Giant but it
was old
and weak
and we were operating at such elevations
and in such Heat
even if we had a six-man Recon team
fully combat loaded only three could be
carried by a ch3 so you'd have to split
the team which is not good tactics and
do two insertions with the ch3
the super jolly green replaced the ch3
the ch-53 the Delta models oh what a
Improvement
in our lives I don't know how many of
our people they could carry because we
never accumulated that many folks well
here with operation tail when they had
over 50 men yeah and Equipment yeah
indeed yeah and uh the a1s never changed
but when I got there we had the O2
the skymaster or something like that
right it's a push-pull airplane it had a
small system a propeller in the front
and a propeller in the back and uh
it was really no good for our operation
because the pilot and the fact Rider sat
side by side
so the uh pilot could Bank to the left
and look down for the landing zone or
the enemy or whatever he's looking at
but then to show the fact writer he'd
have to Circle back to the right and try
to describe what he's talking about and
the other guy would look and no good so
finally ov10s ov10 North American
Rockwell Bronco
fast strong
uh the pilot sits in the front and the
fact rider in the back you both look out
the left you both look out the right you
see the same thing and talk about it
um and they could carry ordinance too
when I got there they had two
rocket pods
seven missiles each
and they said okay these are facts
they're marking targets we'll put
28 white phosphorus marking rounds in
there well we never used all of them
right
and we had four 7.62 machine guns
with zero ammunition
so I set out to try to uh
trade in 14 of the wp missiles for 14
high explosive missiles
and arm the machine guns
and we had a guy we called the Emperor
of Laos it was Ambassador William
Sullivan U.S ambassador to Laos who was
sog's worst enemy worst throughout the
entire secret War worse than the NBA
anything he could do to handcuff us and
[ __ ] us he did
so I would run up this proposal and get
slapped down by Solomon so I enlisted
the world's greatest air Commando Heine
aderholt who had vast experience from
World War II Korea and then he was a
stud with the secret war in terms of
getting assets for
carpeted reconnaissance he was running
the secret War
from the air aspect absolutely in Laos
to include the CIA programs with the
among and general uh whatever his name
was bang Pao indeed
um anyway I said Heine go see the
Ambassador with me
and you talk about an arrogant SOB I
hope you're out there listening you
bastard
um
but he couldn't say no to hiney
so we turned into instant air support
they didn't want to make the ordinance
change because they knew what the facts
would do if the team got in trouble and
the a1s weren't there and we're waiting
for somebody to show up I can personally
attest to that because when we were in
Laos we had launched out of nkp and two
days later we made contact and it was a
fact that came out ov10 is the first
time I've ever seen one yeah let alone
use one and I said hey can you get some
air assets he goes I got some rockets
and we were so happy to hear that he
came in and made gun runs and we never
had Covey or a fact or anybody do gun
runs like that so that was really
vintage stuff it was a step in the right
direction no it was immediate and it was
terrific and I've kind of lost my train
of thought where I was going well here's
here's the key thing on this yeah let's
get back to the reason why you did that
was because as a fact writer you wanted
to see and help the teams on the ground
any way you could and let's just talk
about some of the two more historic
missions that you were on okay but
before you go let me explain how we work
uh you have a whole communication Suite
in the ob-10
so I could talk or the fact writer could
talk to the team on an FM radio
and then I would tell the fact over the
intercom what was going on what was he
needed and then he had UHF and VHF to
deal with the air assets and we would
come up to the Airborne command and
control center in the daytime is
Hillsboro at night it was Moonbeam
and if there was a prairie fire
emergency declared every
airframe in the sky came to us
and so uh the fact would then work the
air support the a1s would bring the
helicopters out hover nearby or the a1s
would participate in this oppression and
when it was ready bring them in
the teams were briefed and prepared in
Vietnam and then they flew over to us on
the blackburns the special ops c-130s
indeed and we had one of these uh we
call them bread trucks it's a shop van
that runs around airfields everywhere
blue that was blue and they had the
curtains inside they had curtains inside
and also a duct tape over the windows
right because that thing would back up
into a C-130
perfectly up the ramp and then you open
the back doors and that was a further
screen indeed put the teams that looked
like Terry and the pirates in the back
or Recon team Idaho Back in 1970 yeah
and drive drive them around to that back
isolation area and and ready to go no
great Hospitality treated really great
there about a staff of course major uh
Bill Shelton was the OIC there
and 70 for how many years how long was
he the officer in charge
um Bill left in 71 yeah and here after
you close F of B1 then he went to nkp
yeah and uh he had a vast experience as
the XO he's a temporary CEO for closing
of fob1
and he was just a natural yeah over
there because it had to be diplomatic
working with all the Air Force people
and a knucklehead from the state
department I assume and meanwhile deal
with the Recon teams when they came in
yeah help for the mission the briefings
Etc yeah he was perfect yes sir
so on
um June 30th uh fact Rider L mazziello
goes out
on a just a visual reconnaissance a VR
which ordinarilies just go fly over
Target look for some lz's and then have
a team or another Recon team his team or
another team go in
and so was he that day was he the
official fact Rider preparing for
another team that's going to launch yeah
he was the principal fact Rider on the
launch Team at nkp that was his
full-time job right and he went out in
an ov10 with a very experienced terrific
uh Forward Air controller
the pilot
Bungalow Bill Sanders
and uh
they descended we were allowed to fly
below their routine minimum altitude
that most facts were required to keep
and they went down to photograph
something and a rocket or a missile of
some sort
hit the side of the aircraft right where
Bill sits
so killed him instantly yeah and then Al
had to punch out literally punch out of
the ov10 I'll uh tried and tried to call
him over the intercom nothing
and it got to where
it's a matter of survival for Al he had
to go a hard decision there was a uh
pull handle between the knees of the
pilot and the fact Rider if the pilot
punched out the back Rider went first
and then he went
if the fact Rider punched out only he
went and that's when I went right
uh he lost his only weapon we just flew
with the pistol it was gone
injured his back
and landed on a ant hill of Plenty
people of NVA in Laos yeah deepenly yes
so uh he had his uh irk 64 was that well
some sort of irk either Eric Tannery 664
yeah he had both by that time he had a
personal survival radio that came up on
the what they call the guard frequency
every aircraft monitored the guard
frequency
so when you turn it on it comes up whoop
whoop whoop they call it a beeper yeah
and then everybody else in the air would
say beeper beeper come up voice
and then they wanted to get you off a
guard so other people would have that
emergency frequency
so uh I was out in the second sortie
that day I was toward the end of his and
and we were out
so people started telling him beeper
beeper or get off uh guard he said the
only radio I have is on guard I'm not
going anywhere
he turned the Beeper off oh yeah
um he knew about where they were
and gave us a good enough location that
we went over there and found him
and so
um the A1 pilots who flew for us
when they became very good and very
experienced they were taken into the
Sandy program
they might be flying for us that day and
the next day they'd be sitting strip
alert as a Sandy for search Air rescue
search and rescue missions
Sandy low lead Sandy one was the boss of
the Tsar okay he told everybody what to
do but he would have about four uh a1s
in his group Sandy's one through four
and they would come out and link up with
the Jolly Green Giant Rescue helicopters
whose motto is uh
That Others May Live That Others May
Live just an incredible model and it's
on the front of their aircraft at that
time and uh and uh so go on to the story
where the first jolly green jolly green
54 and hh-53 Charlie model
was out to rescue them and to look for
Al yeah try to pick them up so uh we had
found Al and uh we vectored the sandies
in and the sandies were using the a1s to
suppress
um enemy fire near the pickup zone and
they would use a fact like us if they
were in the area we fell under Sandy
one's lead and he would hand off f4s or
Air Force or navy fighters to work uh
the periphery right while they're
working the real SAR
and uh
we thought we had it suppressed or Sandy
thought they had it suppressed enough he
sent the Jolly Green in
and a b40 rocket
hit the C hit the h853 rotor head wow
just took the main rotor out
burst into a huge ball of flame
and then he lost all five crew members
obviously no survivors
uh they had gone in before to try to get
in and got shot out
they went back and they decided to go
back
that's the courage of the jolly green
Giants and their Crews they're just
amazing men and then the real courage of
the Jolly greens
the second guy comes back another one
flies in right over
the black spot on the ground that used
to be his wingman
and picked up Al
who we talked to this morning we did
of course today is the anniversary
51st anniversary of that incident June
30th indeed yeah and Al previously he
had run Recon yep out of CCN and highly
respected Recon man there transferred
over to nkp that's how he got our job we
only had good Recon people in the back
except for me
don't be too hard in yourself but and in
that case there the key thing was to
have it have the fact Rider with
experience so they could relate to the
team on the ground and they knew what
they had and what they needed and be
able to tell the pilot so what they
could better coordinate
with the RSS perfect system and uh and
uh you know for a more uh
uh Mission another one that was historic
in nature which is even
um
that was June 30th later that year
SOG did the first Halo jump into Laos
it was RT Florida
Mel Hill was the one zero
Cliff I think was the 1-1 and or it was
Sammy the one Sammy was I think I don't
know either way anyway
everybody says Cliff was a team leader
because he was the first man off of the
ramp right he was the first jumper yes
yeah but Melvin was the one zero indeed
and so in the third American on that
Recon team after they trained in Okinawa
trained up for several months to jump in
the layoffs it was the first Halo jump
high altitude combo combat combat jump
from 18
000 feet and on uh one of the sidebar
notes was they had a black box with them
that in theory when they got underground
that black box would put out a signal
that would get to the other black boxes
so the teams could get together they
just forgot one little point the boxes
were not waterproof and the team jumped
in the Rain from 18 000 feet and those
boxes didn't work when he got on the
ground so you and your fact had to over
the next couple of days finding them
locate them and at some point give them
any support they needed and to bring
them home so uh when do you get the
first call on that you were briefed I
assume on the mission going in
and that sets the background for another
major story from SOG but from your
perspective this is there's a real back
story to this
there always is right uh once a quarter
every three months
I had to go down to Saigon to
participate in the targeting conference
so uh planning you know the next
quarter's activity
so six months before they jumped I went
down
and they announced they planned to have
the first ever combat Halo insertion
on this date in this area oh yeah I
remember that so I raised my hand and I
said
that is not going to happen
that won't work
who are you and what do you know and why
do you say that
so I've been flying up there for quite a
while yeah and uh
they used to express cloud coverage in
Eights
so eight eighths was complete overcast
yeah I said that area at that time of
year will be eight H cloud coverage and
raining
so I was told I was full of beans by a
first lieutenant Air Force meteorologist
and the planning proceeded
so uh
they went to Okinawa they talked a
couple of indigenous guys to Free Fall
who maybe had never been in an airplane
before in their life until they ran
Recon well yeah there's we're good we're
going to get Clifford and or Sammy in
here oh good about that day yes good
absolutely because they did train up
there and digit on their team yeah yeah
amazing so uh
I don't know how many aborts they had
but the night they jumped they went up
a classic legendary Halo guy the guy
taught me Halo in Germany Frank norbury
was the jump Master wow
and the commander of the ground studies
group up 35 and mcvey's SOG headquarters
a full colonel was riding along in the
back just as a spectator
for which he received the distinguished
flying cross
I'll go unnamed uh yeah Frank norbury
did not calculate the release point
where to jump from
they used an Air Force system called
carp the computed air release Point ooh
so they put them out
the key to Halo is grouping
doesn't matter where you land as long as
you land together indeed then the unit
can operate
you group
in free fall you can control your
movements almost like swimming
once the low man opens his canopy
everybody opens their canopy and you
group during
descent under canopy and hopefully you
all land together
that team could not see each other in
free fall they could not see each other
under canopy and they landed in six
different places
miles and miles from their intended Drop
Zone
yeah even off the map that They Carried
with them we always carried cut down
Maps so you know for security huge sheet
of paper to fool with
and it had your area in a few kilometers
around
none of those people had any map sheet
anywhere near where they were standing
on the ground in Laos
so the weather was also unworkable for
us
wow so we go out and start looking for
them
and we start looking where they're
supposed to be and there ain't nothing
and nobody's on the radio
in the meantime Cliff stumbles across
one of the mountain yards
and they had a uh I was surprised at
this uh Army of the Republic of Vietnam
Arvin Lieutenant with them and we didn't
have many Arvin around us
and that lieutenant and another Mountain
yard they got together
Sammy all alone and Melvin all alone so
now we've got four groups of people
no map sheet don't know where they are
raining like hell and away we go deep in
Leos
so uh one day I was in the back seat of
a now retired Air Force Brigadier
General who wound up being a pow in the
Hanoi Hilton right wonderful fellow Jim
Latham
and he was new to our program
so we're out flying around I'm calling
and calling and finally on the FM radio
I hear oh
and so we start trying to do radio
Direction finding trying to get his
voice to come in
is that a louder or 10 frequency or FM
no FM FM yeah the team radio sure yeah
so we get to where their voice is pretty
good and now we want to go down and get
a visual on them
and we're in terrible mountains
and there's clouds everywhere
and you get these what they call sucker
holes
that you can fly down through
and there may be a mountain in there or
maybe not and then when you do your
thing then you don't know how to get
back out and you're flying through
thousands of feet of clouds or rain or
all the above uh horrible indeed
so I told Jim you think you can get down
through that hole
he said I'll try
so we're going down going down he said
you guys do this often
I said every day
it's another dance hog so we get down
and everybody carried a a little
signaling mirror
it's got an Aiming hole in the middle
and oh yeah you can then try to put it
on the airplane and I saw Cliff Newman's
shiny no kidding yeah
wow and so that was I think on the third
day
might have been the second but I think
the third yeah and then it took us uh at
least two and maybe three more days
to get marginally marginally workable
weather to get the a1s and the
helicopters in there
and
there was uh Air Base South of nakapanon
called uban
and if we had our extreme Southern
targets we would move a temporary launch
site down to ubon that's where we were
working
so almasiello and his pilot Dick Hall
they go out and locate them and come
back and and breathe okay we're ready to
go
and the helicopter said we ain't going
really in this weather
and Dick Hall the captain talking to a
squadron commander lieutenant colonel
said you are going you Colonel you
coward or I'll shoot you right here no
yep got a point
away they go
so we have four pickup sites now and
instead of one
and they got the two groups of two and
they got Sammy
Melvin hadn't been heard on the radio
yet we have no clue where Melvin is
and we're about to give up on him and
leave
and he stepped out from inside the old
hollowed-out rotten tree really where
he's been holed up
and they got Melvin and away we went wow
yeah
but that was the absolute height of
foolishness and not given a good damn
about great people indeed to put them
out like that so you can write down that
you accomplished the first Halo Mission
it was hailed as a great accomplishment
they didn't accomplish a damn thing
except living yeah survival became the
primary mission one more time
unbelievable indeed and then you're all
part of that how many sorties in between
trying to find them well let's see if
they were out there five or six days it
was uh 15 or 18 sorties at least yeah oh
yeah my God yeah a lot of time in the
air
and you know you're in dangerous because
here's what my next point is when we
talk about flying across the trail
people think oh you're an airplane
there's the Ho Chi Minh trail which by
1970 had vastly increased uh
anti-aircraft capabilities on the trail
and because in November of 68 President
Johnson had stopped bombing up north and
a lot of the anti-aircraft Weaponry from
there was shipped South and so just for
a second or two talk a little bit about
what it was like just to cross the trail
well they the Air Force had adopted a
strategy of jinking you didn't fly
straight and level across the trail
because you did you'd get shot yeah you
left right up down
uh I was talking to you this morning
about uh a great photo I have of one of
the ch3s before we shifted the 53s
was flying back with a team inside and
the ramp opened
and a 37 millimeter which is quite a any
aircraft gun uh the round entered the
helicopter through the ramp and hit the
fuselage and exploded on the way out
that's a historic picture of that hole
oh yeah and uh who's the one zero David
no no David Carr was uh if I'm not
mistaken was Recon company Commander
okay and he went out with the team okay
and that team was coming back wow but I
know that David was in that aircraft yes
and then I sent him that photo 50 years
later
that's a heck of a picture and you know
uh there's some other stories one that
just has a little bit of levity but a
high degree of seriousness to it is one
of our uh Recon men
Robert Master Joseph
and his 1-0 was uh Mike Dugan and one of
a highly respected one zeros out of CCN
they came over to nkp again because of
the weather they had the launch from nkp
and uh this was Bob's early first
mission or very first mission and during
the briefing at some point there was
this discussion about we we really want
to get a pow yeah and they're talking
back and forth and Mike Dugan goes well
give us a Target and of course your
people had a perfect Target it had a lot
of high activity and you said we can
find it for you and master Joseph spoke
up saying I'd give my left nut
to get a pow yeah so for taking from
there they launched into this deadly
Target area and then there's a little
bit of background to that uh please you
know they'd arrive in nkp and have one
evening before we'd put them in the next
day yeah so we'd sit around talk with
them and uh Master Joseph said I hope we
make contact tomorrow I need to get my
combat infantry badge my CIB
and uh Mike Dugan said uh no we run good
Recon on uh RT Massachusetts
and the uh objective is not to make
contact
and chief you're going to be the only
guy to ever run Recon for one year in
CCN and go home without a CIB Oh no I
got to get my Cid in it he said but what
I would really I would give my left nut
for a prisoner yeah so I told Mike I
said if you guys want a prisoner I
forget their mission was just some kind
of area Recon this is a bad area yeah
they have some Limestone outcroppings
that are tall
mountainous
bear Rock call karst over there and uh
in their area I mean we could get away
with putting them there uh was this big
karst with a big cave at the bottom of
it
and trails came out of that cave and
they looked like a peacock's tail or
something they just fanned in every
direction countless Trails going in this
cave I said
Mike there's something going on in that
cave we don't know what it is but I'm
sure they would love to know in Saigon
because there were rumors probably you
heard that there were American pows
being held in karst oh yeah caves yeah
so we would like to uh find out what's
going on there
I said if you want to try to get a
prisoner
we will put you down
not 10 feet in front of the cave but out
in front of that cave
and the helicopters and the a1s are not
going anywhere
because you're going to be in there 10
or 20 minutes I think yeah
so at that time getting a prisoner was a
big deal in SOG always a big deal oh the
little people got a hundred bucks each
and we say that lovingly we loved our
indigenous troops indeed uh they got a
hundred dollars which was hell of a lot
of money for them and uh the Americans
would give maybe a Seiko watch and a
free r r trip and anywhere in the world
yeah so he said yeah let's let's go for
it
so we put them down and the helicopters
moved two minutes away and they weren't
in there 10 minutes and we got a radio
call
that said uh
we have a prisoner and we have one
wounded American
so we always sent one more helicopter
than was required to lift the team with
a medic on board we called it the chase
ship right so if somebody was wounded
you send the chase ship in first to get
the team out that way the medic intent
to the wounded yeah so Johnny Hannah was
the
Chase medic
they go out he calls up and he says
Chief got his wish
and so when we get back to the launch
side and start hearing more of this
story
an AK-47 round
just clipped barely clipped the bottom
of chief Master Joseph scrotum
and the left one fell out
and dangled down to knee level on this
little squiggly conduit indeed the chief
says doc can you save it
and Johnny says doc it looks like you're
going to get your wish yeah
I kided one ball for this Mission so the
things the things we laugh about now my
wife is always uh
uh
uh can't believe the stories we tell and
then just laugh like hell
yeah Master Joseph was quite a character
in his own right he used to come to our
reunion which is kind of wild and crazy
sometimes he brought his mom to the
reunion every year I remember
so uh so on a personal note again before
you became a fact writer at nkp you
spent time on the ground not only
running Recon out of CCS but also a
couple of missions out of CCN so that
gives you the background experience of
being the time on the ground and then
also prior to that your experience in
the mic for us so if you could take us
back a little bit wind us back because
even in the mic for us some of the
veterans that have been there said well
you saw guys you ran Recon you tried to
run low profile maintain low profile if
you made contact you escaping of Aid and
go home your compromise Mike Force our
job was to defend an a camp helping a
camp or to go hunting EA which they've
done with with historic results and
so you land in Vietnam and take it from
there your first assignment because your
tour is going to Ben het Etc that is
just another sidebar to this we'll come
back to some other SOG stuff a little
bit but for your background which is
part of your amazing story
the uh the story began in Germany
I was in the 10th Special Forces Group
indeed I joined them totally unqualified
and and went through their trainings
there and became SF qualified and I got
orders to Vietnam I had a wonderful
wonderful NCO on my A-Team
that had served in the two-core mic
Force
in Vietnam it was divided up for command
and control into four cores
and each core had a mobile Strike Force
in mic Force
and a number of Aid attachments located
in camps and the uh indigenous people
who lived near those camps would be paid
a low salary and they're supposed to
defend that area
and then the mic force a different
number of a teams in each core we had
five in two core
we had a team
in command no Vietnamese counterparts of
a battalion of local indigenous I had
450 route a mountain yards
but I didn't know much about any of that
um back in Germany and I have this
wonderful NCO Peter Holmberg and I get
orders to Vietnam and I said Pete where
should I go he said oh go to Mike Force
if you can go to two core mic for us
don't go to SOG everyone gets killed
okay everyone gets killed so my orders
were to the 173rd Airborne Brigade oh I
didn't want to go that's not SF I didn't
want to go to that
so the guy who got me in Special Forces
had been the S1 the Personnel guy for
the 10th group major Jim crisell retired
major general commanded the 25th
Infantry Division it was a great great
guy
he was now at the fifth group
headquarters in netrang
as that's three
so my airplane landed in Cameron Bay
and they said everyone line up over here
and then process well I went to the
nearest telephone I called Jim Christo
and I said I don't want to go to the
173rd can you get me to group
he said my roommate in the boq is the
group S1
oh don't talk to anyone don't call me
back in an hour and a half so I called
him back and he said okay he said
they're so mad at us we keep stealing
these guys they said you can have it but
the next guy that gets off that plane
for the fifth group is going to the
173rd turned out to be a good friend of
mine was that Pat McGuire oh in a year
so uh I I go up to uh
the C team
in charge and uh
play cool
and three captains walk in
and the deputy Commander says where do
you want to go and the first guy says
well I'm a previous tour I come into a
camp I'm coming up for major I would
like to be on the higher level staff so
I can prove I can work with it okay
the next guy says
I'm I'm not very confident about
commanding an A-Team in combat could I
work in the S3 shop or something for six
months and then I'll go to the field
I said I want to go the two-core Mike
Force he said you're going where you
want
he told that first guy you're going to
command ASO and so at a certain camp and
he told poor Pat Kingsley you're going
to command The A-Team at been hit and
this is before before the stuff hit the
fan
been head at one time was taking 1500
rounds a day of artillery and Rockets
and I mean it was just horrible and
where was Ben head located it's on right
on the border
um
into core to the West I think it's
probably west of Contin I would say yeah
it's south of duck pack and dakto and
those but anyway
we had five battalions and two core and
for the longest time during that Siege
we kept
two or three of our five battalions at
Bennett wow there were several regiments
walking around of Hardcore NBA walking
around out there that's three thousand
enemy with year 400 yeah 400 versus
you're 450. so I told you the story
about my Battalion and I looked into a
hand-picked A-Team indeed by a guy who
had been a command sergeant major and
got a direct commission to Captain and
he was allowed to hand pick his old
buddies from the first group
wonderful wonderful a team some rock
stars yeah and uh he was getting too old
he couldn't hump the highlands in two
course so I got his team and away we go
to Ben hit
one day we climbed a mountain and we
found a regimental defensive position
dug in
that looked like an Engineer Battalion
at Fort Benning had dug it as a training
aid of how this is how you would do your
perfect so you walked into an enemy camp
that at that point was not occupied with
enemy soldiers we could smell them
their cook fires were still warm
wow you could smell the rice
where they had removed the tripods and
things for their weapons the dirt had
not begun crumbling yet I mean they had
just left
so they had this worthless major from
the two core mic Force up there as the
Task Force Commander because we had
multiple battalions up there right
so I called and reported and he said oh
this is great
divide your Battalion up into the three
companies so that'd be a hundred and
fifty right people
separate them by at least one kilometer
each
and find that regiment oh
I said no sir we are not going to do
that
I've got 14 year old Soldiers carrying
M1 carbines still yeah
and uh if we find that regiment we'll be
decimated and we're not going to do that
he said you're defying a direct order in
combat I said you bet you're bippy pal
we'll talk this out when I get home when
I hung up the NCO said that's the best
radio call I ever heard in my life that
night and you live to talk about it but
that night people did not live to talk
about it that night our sister Battalion
in the valley just south of us
got lit up
the Battalion Commander killed they were
Australian team we had Aussies
commanding some of the teams right yes
uh Keith Payne won the Victoria Cross
their Medal of Honor yeah
they were decimated that Battalion never
went to the field again parceled out the
survivors to other units and everything
is that right yeah so I'm so glad I
thought
yeah thank you for following your common
sense so you're right uh Mike force and
um
SOG two sides of the special ops coin uh
we would stay in the field uh up to a
month
you didn't smell very good your clothes
weren't in very good shape uh a month
yeah no bass no no bad
but we could get resupplied which a
Recon team you'd never want to get a a
resupply no yeah
yeah
my God so from there you hear about
Mac visag not much
I don't know how I knew
that Colonel Isler
who had commanded CCN
had moved down to Saigon and he
was in command of ground studies Group
which owned all the cnc's Recon teams
uh it's too long a story to go into but
uh my beat Team Commander a major
got some bad poop about two of my ncos
he got drunk out of his mind
he called me and Batman to it and said
you and those two sons of [ __ ] get up
here today
I said sir the less milk run has has
just left he said I don't give a damn
you get up here today
I said well first you'll have to
identify the two sons of [ __ ]
and one was an SF legend that after
retired round Camp McCall many years
Lowell Stevens had run recon at Contin
and Donnie Simmons who was a big big
name in The Scuba community at Key West
for many years and then he went to Delta
and became a legend in Delta
two of the greatest guys and here's this
major he's down on him because he's
gotten some really false Intel
so we were billeted at Bama to it East
Airfield and at night the airlift
control element wanted to pull their com
trailer into our compound so it'd be
secure when they all in all
so they owed us they turned around a
c123 that had left family to it for
pleco
picked three of us up and take us
so that major harangued us drunk out of
his mind all evening fired us kicked us
out of the mic for us so we went across
the street to the Sea team they were
having a floor show at the club that
night we three sitting there here came
all the mic for us guys the majors
talking trash about us all night and
then by the end of the
floor show he said oh come come on back
you guys are Mike Force You Belong with
us so we go back over
we're in the mess hall
and he flip-flops again and he gets in
all three of us face as has lined up his
attention just cursing and swearing
everything
so one of the three of us who will
remain unnamed punched him right in the
mouth I mean his lip exploded like a
giant grape
did you cut your knuckle no okay
you're not going there
uh
the next morning he called us in he had
that big
and apologized and he said we could stay
and those two guys decided to stay I
said no I'm out of here I can't work
right anymore
so uh I called the Iceman I had worked
for Isler in Germany
we played handball together and by then
he was a full full version
yeah I was a captain it started out he
was a lieutenant colonel I was at first
lieutenant odd relationship but we were
best handball opponents in Germany in
Germany and I
my wife and I uh babysat his kids and so
we were tight so I called him and said
uh
I I need a home I gotta go
he said CCS was right across the street
but I didn't know anything about them or
what they did he said go over there tell
the commander I sent you there to run
Recon
so the first three times I went into
Cambodia I wasn't on the unit roster the
orders hadn't come through I don't know
what would happen if I hadn't come wow
yeah so that's how I pass through the
mic for six months and came to CCS
welcome the song yeah thank God thank
God uh
I wouldn't trade anything for my time in
shock indeed yeah well that's that's
that's saying something in and of itself
and so from there you spent some time
then after 12 missions you spend some
time as a desk officer for op 35 before
you go up to CCN before you go to nkp
but even there are some valuable
insights as to how the secret war was
conducted I think
um
first of all Jim starter who had run
Recon CCN a captain he's been an
instructor at Ranger school terrific guy
he was the CCN desk officer at their
higher headquarters up 35 right and his
dad was passing away he needed to go
home on a compassionate reassignment and
I think it dawned on Isler that here's
his buddy the little Captain out there
that may not come back and he didn't
want that happening on his watch
so he pulled me to up to 35 as the CCN
desk officer again six months I couldn't
hold a job over six months
so then at some point they flip you up
to CCN and Danang
and then you you
this is the thing I like about your
story because you've you come to CCN
it's a different AO and you said before
I do anything I want to run some Recon
and you did no no no no tell me how no
that's why we're here
I go up to uh CCN to end process they
kept all our payroll records Personnel
records right Logistics we were attached
to them
for
admin and Logistics okay but we were
operational control of op 35. we were
SOG headquarters alongside not ccn's
launch site right
so I arrive up there and I ask is there
any way to fly uh visual reconnaissance
a VR out over this ccnao
I was used to the ccsaao L operation
area
um
not to denigrate CCS at all they ran
good Recon down there and some real
heroes
uh highly decorated people yeah boy Ben
and vides earned his Medal of Honor on a
CCS Target people that should have been
awarded and weren't has happened in much
of sog
nothing whatsoever against them no
but you fly over Cambodia
and you fly over Northern Prairie Fire
and tell me it's the same thing well I'm
biased but
I flew out that day
and it looked like The Interchange of
I-65 and I-40 with all the state road
feeders and clover leaves and on-ramps
and the Ho Chi Minh trail was not a
trail I can assure you
mountains mountains mountains mountains
increasing anti-aircraft and enemy
people running around that you could see
no kidding I mean even from your VR oh
yeah oh yeah NBA and pith helmets with
ak-40 and there wasn't any SKS and uh no
floppy hat no no train soldiers
so I came back and I didn't think I
belonged in the Recon club which is
where I would have liked to be with the
guys sure
but I won in Recon company and so I went
up to the
rear Echelon pukes
the club and I'm standing there talking
to a friend of mine can't remember who
it was
but the commander of CCN who turned out
to be a total ass
and I hope I get a chance to tell you
the story of operation Cherry Bark ooh
was standing behind me and I didn't know
it
and I said
I don't know how you get people to run
Recon out there
and if you do
I don't know how you get any of them
back
well no kidding
so this guy said the colonel says well
you're a goddamn coward and I'm not
going to have a coward working at my
launch site
I said well first of all it's not your
launch site
that's Colonel listeners on site and
chief songs not your lunch right
you do the paperwork for them
that's about it I said and I am not a
coward I will go out with any Recon team
you have would you like to go with us oh
I have important business in this
another
so I walked out I was mad so I won't hit
him though no
or the other guy not not proven
so I walked down knuckle first let me
show you
I walked down to the uh Recon Club yeah
and ran into our friend
the other Legend I mean deserved Legend
Eldon Bardwell indeed and I told him my
story
and he took me over the guy he liked and
respected called Ron Ray
oh yeah
and uh Ron was sitting there with his
1-1
and I said uh
I need to shut up your commander up
there I need to strap hang with somebody
he said I don't take strap hangers
but ask Randy if he'll let you carry the
radio you can go as the one too
Randy Suber is the 1-1 yeah yeah
so I ran two missions with them just
I wanted to
establish some Bona fides with the Recon
guys sure there and you did I mean you
get on the ground twice and then one
target it sounded like you had a
successful mission five days on the
ground five days on the ground uh
watching a river crossing
and the other one was relative success
in the ash out we stayed two days in the
actual that's a long stay
before you get chased out yeah under
heavy enemy gunfire well under some
gunfire indeed yeah so this is all now
we're talking the summer or late 69
really late 69. right before
Ron and Randy yeah November 10th 1969.
went missing yeah on uh November 3rd we
had our team Maryland
that uh all the Americans were killed
the Indian did survived and then on
November 10th that team went down this
those two men are still amongst the 50
Green Berets who are M.I.A today
uh from the secret war in Laos and just
out you know you and I are biased we
knew we knew them they were just studs
and uh they were they were good in the
woods they were they were no and so
after that experience at some point you
go over to nkp yeah and you do your
missions there and um you know I think
one of those other stories people talk
about the ironies of Life how things
unfold
um when you're at CCS you met an
outstanding Recon man down there who was
a fellow officer
Captain Don Carr
and the you had some interesting times
down there with him and uh
um
take just a little bit more background
how you two got together and then how
later on he was calling you a ref and
you and that kind of thing
um
at ccs and I expect maybe it's on the
other cnc's
a new guy was not welcomed with open
arms and became your best friend right
away because some of them didn't last
too long and you didn't want to be
invested in
yeah the personal the personality side
of it sure
Don Won that way with me he was very
good friend very nice and he had a
silver star from a previous tour
I really respect and admired him
again he was a captain also yeah sure
and uh
so when the Iceman pulled me down to
Saigon
Don just couldn't help but laugh and
laugh and call me a rimp a rear Echelon
MF
[Laughter]
so I go down to Saigon I work a while
and uh
the CCS desk officer was leaving and
needed replacement oh so I told Isler I
know the perfect guy I haha
so he pulled Don Carr down there oh and
he never could prove I had anything to
do with it I asked him who's a rep now
you know yeah indeed so then I go up to
nkp and uh am the Ops officer and flying
uh for a year
and the S3 the operations officer at CCC
was leaving
well-known guy
and I got a call that said you're going
to go to Contin and replace this guy
right
and I didn't want to go I mean nkp was
Heaven oh you're fighting the secret war
in the day and you're living in safety
in Thailand at night it was wonderful
and because we were stationed in denang
and TDY to nkp we drew per diem every
day that's right I forgot that side of
the queen TD extra money when you have
to go on temporary Duty oh yeah you're a
filthy rich compared to us peons
or I wasted more than you wish
so anyway they told me Don Carr is going
to come replace you and I felt so happy
for nkp yeah they couldn't have gotten a
better guy because he had already
experience it prerequisites are in place
and he was a tough good Recon
personality team member
indeed Aces
so don comes up and I uh pack up my
stereo gear and I'm just waiting we have
about a one week overlap
and uh
he flew a couple of times
uneventful
and uh
I took him to the aircraft
to go out again
and they didn't come back
indeed and uh
Saigon told me we don't have anybody
else to replace it with right now so
unpacking stage so I stayed another year
and that's just one of those horrible
moments in time where it's a good friend
the comrade Norms comes up slate to
replace you and then goes out on a
mission that you could have been on and
I thought about that many many times I
probably went out 150 times before him
and 150 after
and he went out about maybe five times
right
yeah you can't explain it except I do
explain it now to myself
he was new
yeah his Pilot was new also I forgot the
pilot was new also for the Air Force
and uh
I wasn't in that duty position anymore
but I had a voice
and I should have said those two
shouldn't go out together but it never
crossed my mind
because all those guys over there were
such Pros oh yeah
uh
and we don't know what happened
it was like the time we found the Halo
team
bad bad mountains bad bad weather
clouds everywhere and fearless Pilots
that got you through and to find these
guys but they didn't have any mission
that would have required that as far as
I know there was only and and this
shouldn't matter but in all Vietnamese
team right
in the area only the one team they
weren't in trouble
and they reported hearing a loud boom
we don't know if it was any aircraft
fire right I suspect they ran into a
mountain
okay yeah wow and that they were into
their sortie
they should have called us and said
we're checking out and coming home
we flew that oh they found the aircraft
many many years later and brought Danny
and Don home indeed yeah
and uh the pilots that Dan young Thomas
Thomas Dan Thomas Young first lieutenant
yeah
that's just again the secret war with
this just traumatic repercussions you
never know what's going to happen when
you're on the ground or on the air over
a Target because people
you know that's one of the reasons why
we're here with you is to talk about
that side of it that that brought you
there yeah you know I drove him to the
airplane he had his survival vest and
his head and all that laughing and
joking and he climbs up in the canopy
and we just wave and away they go just
another day at nkp yeah yeah
and it turned out to be a crappy crappy
day at nkp oh
I can't imagine
and uh through it all you had to march
on for another year
and then you know how many times over
your 300 plus missions how many times
did you fly in an aircraft that you take
incoming you have rounds of shrapnel
uh many times you don't know you're
getting shot at the only times you know
about is uh when you come back with
holes in there correct you don't feel
the no is that right because you have
small arms no I mean if a 23 or 37 hits
you yeah but well when we were flying
over locate the uh
Halo team right Sammy comes up and says
hey you guys Don't Go Near That Village
they're shooting the crap out of you
every time you go by there we had no
idea no and when we landed the tail was
full of holes
just didn't hit a control wire or the
gas tank or anything like that oh my god
well
um one of the things that we had talked
about before we didn't get any details
was Operation Cherry Bark
okay is that something we can't talk
about or I want to don't sound like uh
yeah let's do that I want to talk about
that and I want to name names oh
this guy should be shamed
on every platform he can be shamed on
Awards and decorations in sog
is a little bit difficult to talk about
because we had more Medal of Honor
winners per capita than any unit
Bob Howard should have gotten three yeah
he's put in for three and the first one
is downgraded to DSC the second one was
approved and when they opened up the
third one they said ain't nobody getting
two
so he got another DSC yeah so it's hard
to say
that SOG was crap
on Awards and decorations when you have
that evidence but
how many people do we know like Gary
Robb who ran amazing Recon he's the only
guy I knew that went with one American
him his team and he began with two hoys
three former NBAs who had left them and
came to us
you know what his highest award is
Army Commendation Medal with a V device
which is nothing
and that's a thanks for participating
thing
okay I told you I had to go to Saigon
right for the
targeting conference
so I get a call one day
oh it was fun to go down there because
they had a little Learjet that did uh
Courier runs oh yeah the officers got
that yeah yeah so I got a Learjet to
Saigon and back every three months oh my
God so they called me and said uh the
admin NCO is going to pick you up at the
scat back
and you're to go over to the uh McVee
military assistance command Vietnam
Inspector General office
and I thought crap what do they know
about now
so I get there and this uh
full kernel Inspector General
shows me a letter from Chief sogg that
says he's authorized to know anything
and everything
and to be fully Cooperative with him
and he said what do you know about
operation Cherry Bark
I said well when I worked in op 35
up 80 which was the joint Personnel
Recovery Center the pow Mia guys right
came down and said hey we've got some
Intel from down in four chord down in
the Delta somebody is saying he's seen
some American prisoners of War
we don't want to gen up any units down
there because they'll know locally
something is up
so we want to gen up a hatchet Force
these are the larger CCN units right
that go in ready for Bear ready to fight
like a mini mic Force almost yeah
absolutely same thing
um
but before
we deploy anybody
this guy's name was Major gem rabdau a
great big SF guy real good guy said I'm
going down to four Court to get better
more complete Intel and I want Mike to
go with me so we go down there
and we find out that this guy maybe he
heard from another guy who may be heard
that over in this general area there
might have been some blah blah nothing
too many movies not actionable
whatsoever
so we come back to Saigon the whole
thing is scrubbed
no one ever went anywhere or did
anything except maybe me and Jim RAB
doll went and had a nice lunch and
talked to her
horrible informant yeah
so this Colonel says and that's all you
know about operation Cherry Bark I said
yes he said well read this and see how
this jives with your memory
the name the name was blacked out
but Lieutenant Colonel blank
was flying above his
Hatchet Force company
that was trying to free some pows
and he got word that uh one of his
people was wounded
and trying to get to the LZ with her
uh pow enemy not a freed American right
and uh so he told his command and
control helicopter to land on that piece
of terrain and we're going to pick up
this wounded guy and this prisoner
the guy is struggling with his wounds to
get to the helicopter so Lieutenant
Colonel blank jumps out of his
helicopter runs across the LZ and
assists the wounded man and the Prisoner
and gets them all in the helicopter
hahaha
Silver Star
for jumping out of the helicopter and
running over there and getting that guy
really soldiers medal
for saving the wounded guy's life
as they're lifting out the door gunner
gets shot
the colonel pulls him out of his seat
the lieutenant colonel sits at the door
Gunner's machine gun and fires up the
enemy as they leave
distinguished flying cross
three very high metals
in 15 minutes that's that's metal
harvesting at its best that didn't
happen oh my God that my friend is
nothing
that is not the tip of the iceberg
so he typed up a statement that I signed
saying none of this occurred
never happened
he said let me show you something
you know the brown paper all rolled up
butcher Butcher paper he unrolls his
chart
the left hand where the x-axis
is the DSC
down to probably the Good Conduct metal
every metal we have except the Medal of
Honor
and then the bar graph across y was
color-coded
Red Army channels
blue Air Force channels green Arvin
channels
and across the y-axis was submitted
approved or sent to higher headquarters
approved there or sent to the next
higher headquarters
this guy
Lieutenant Colonel Donahue
West Poynter
non-s-f tanker put into command CCN by
General Abrams tanker who aided Special
Forces indeed had caused himself to be
put in for every medal we have other
than the Medal of Honor here's how they
got him
the DSC
you have to have weather to rain
vegetation you have to have everything
detailed
eyes dotted T's crossed
it got to Department of the army
and they said this is lacking certain
things send it back to the guy who
submitted it
for correcting it
the name and the signature attached
there was Colonel Jack Isler
now retired
issler says not my signature
not my submission
all lies
the next signature up the chain was
Anthony Zerby Air Force 06 deputy chief
Sugg
he said not my signature not my
submission
you know what they did to Donahue
what did they do allowed to retire with
floral pension and benefits no yep
so I hope you're out there Donahue
listening to this I live in Anacortes
Washington I'm easy to find indeed or
just come to the SOA meeting where
there's so many of us that do not like
you sir
oh he won't come to that no but
one-on-one if you want to defend
what you consider your honor
please
I invite you I'll pick you up at the
Seattle airport
hahaha
well it um one of the burning issues
that you and I've talked about off to
Mike today quickly referred to it
um is the whole pow Mia issue itself and
uh first of all how many years of
military service all together 25 25 and
um that included a couple of interesting
tours of Duty
in foreign countries that we could talk
a little bit about yeah I became a
Middle East foreign area officer so I
spent multiple tours in Saudi Arabia and
one in Egypt that's under the state
department no no under DOD yeah DOD has
what's called security assistance
organizations and they all have
different names yeah sure but they're
out there to train advise assist and
manage foreign military sales cases sure
yeah so the in Saudi Arabia they have
two Armed Forces they have their
Ministry of defense and then they have a
separate Saudi Arabian National Guard
which is not like our National Guard
they're like a royal guard they're
anti-koo Force if anybody in the army or
Air Force anything ever tried to
overthrow the king the Saudi Arabian
National Guard will go knock them out
that's who I was with right and you were
helping train them up uh yeah
and also wasn't there somebody had a
little bit of a link there a unique link
that introduced you to all that the
Saudis well it didn't introduce me to it
he he helped me yes uh the Saudis
decided they wanted to form Delta
a version of Delta indeed so our dear
friend Eldon
Parts wrote At first the one the only I
don't know if he was commanding Delta
then or had a squadron or what I think
he was the commander
and I called him and said can you come
with a small mobile training team and
help me out dear
and uh before you come you should
realize you know they're not going to be
a Delta but if we can give them any
capabilities you know sure yeah so he
did Elton and three or four guys came
over yeah
and then later you were involved in
Egypt with the hijacking takedown on
Malta
I
had gone on a vacation to Cairo with my
wife and we said how would you like to
live in this
Heap
and we both said no way yeah uh so I
leave Saudi Arabia I go back to Fort
Bragg for the foreign area officer
course and I get a call said we need to
go you to go back to the region
uh the uh
Marine Barracks had been bombed in
Lebanon yeah and the uh commission that
studied it decided they needed more
uh people that spoke the language had
recent experience in the region needed
more of us over there
so they said
we really need you to go to Egypt
so I went home and I told Laura here's a
chance
to work SF
duties and fair duties same time Connie
Connie unique
can you put up with two years in Cairo
so she's a real trooper and indeed the
way we went
while we were there there was at least
one terrorist type attack like the
achille lauro right
during my tour wow and one was the
hijacking of an Egypt Air
craft that was leaving Athens
and I think headed for Cairo and these
guys hijacked them and took them to
Malta
and they started uh
shooting hostages in the head
and tossing them out the door up at that
height all right tarmac
The Maltese are in bed with the libyans
they did not want to allow the U.S or
UK or anybody in there
they said the Egyptians could go
777 is the name of that unit
and uh they asked the U.S for some help
they wanted escort Fighters off the
Mediterranean
aircraft carriers
as they passed by Libya
they were afraid Libyan Egypt were bad
enemies
right they're afraid their C-130 full of
Commandos would get shot down
so the U.S said okay we'll escort you
and they said we would like an American
on board rc-130
really so that we're sure that the Navy
will protect the C-130
oh my God so away I go is that right
along with two other guys yeah
in the movie The Green Berets which Tom
loves there there's a
Asian American he's Hawaiian
who plays the Vietnamese General that
they kidnap and send him up in the
Skyhook that's a guy named Bill olds
okay he is DSF sure yeah know that name
and then our boss in Cairo a guy named
Brigadier General Wiegand who used to
command this Center in schools at Bray
so uh
General Wiegand puts out the word that
we're going to travel in desert
camouflage and green berets
all of the terrorists are in uh Nike
track suits and blue jeans and as they
should be yeah
so we land in Malta and here's the
Maltese government standing there and
they're British advisors and three Green
Berets get off and they went through the
goddamn roof man they were mad
so we were not allowed to accompany the
Commandos on the raid we were
held at the control tower no kidding
and they went out there and like many
good demo people
they calculated the size of the charge
that could breach the fuselage
and then tripled it and doubled it again
everything
they claim that their breach attempt did
not set the airplane on fire
they say that the terrorists through a
thermite grenade and that set it on fire
it's on that piece of paper
the
first word I got from the Commandos and
Commandos over the radio it was mission
success we freed all the hostages
well they were free but 58 out of 95 I
think the numbers are on there where
they are right burned up
wow yeah
not a good day
my God not a good day no the sad thing
Eldon and those guys were ready to come
they were in sigonella
and one of my roles was if the Egyptian
Commandos needed any special equipment
or advice expertise I was to call Eldon
and get the
whatever they needed well that's all
right they were standing by they were
ready to go oh and for them piece of
cake yeah
58 people probably still be alive
my God
well moving right along sir as I said
the pow Mia issue which is deep in our
hearts and you've done some significant
work there
is a couple of veterans associations
that are formed by Special Forces
the one that's uh probably nearest and
dearest to our hearts are the special
operations Association formed
by the Recon men and then later Hatchet
Force
and the founder was Jim Butler our first
1-0 and his number is zero zero one and
uh there's a special forces Association
and
over the years the SOA has been actively
involved with
the different government agencies that
they keep changing the name today is the
dpaa the department of pow Mia
accounting ability accounting agency
and in 2013
you were appointed as chairman of the
SOA SFA p-o-w-m-a committee no you're on
the committee no how'd that work besides
I thought president the president of
this Special Operations Association was
a guy named John Striker tilt Meyer
and at our reunion one year he walked
out of the board meeting or whatever the
high muckety mucks were doing and said
come here Mike you've been a member of
this organization for over 40 years
you've never done a damn thing for us I
want you to head the pow Mia committee
well the issue is close to our hearts so
I said I'd be glad to
I didn't know much about the status of
the mission uh at all
my wife and I were on an RV trip on the
east coast and the national league of
pow Mia families was getting ready to
have their annual meeting
and they have all the high-level DOD
muckity mucks come and speak and then
the family speak and so I went to that
and I have a partner annual briefing
yeah I learned so much at that
and then I uh started calling people
like Cliff Cliff Newman you yeah spider
parks
and forming Wade ishimoto
uh SF
you know creaming the crop guys to form
this committee so that when we said
something people would know who we were
and listen
and then I realized it was only the SOA
powmie committee
I was writing letters to the president
United States to Congress to sect death
and I was speaking on behalf of 2 000
people
so at that time Cliff Newman was uh
executive director of the Special Forces
Association much larger than us because
anybody who's SF qualified can join
and Cliff had been the prior president
of the SOA many years before that yeah
had been a board director Etc and now he
was executive director of the sffa so I
call Cliff
and I said this won't cost you guys any
money
we would like to add you to the
committee as the SFA representative
and we would like to be a joint
soasfa committee
so he ran it past their board and they
agreed so now I could say
we're writing on behalf of twelve
thousand
special operators would you lie because
most of the 2000 are also members of the
ten thousand but who's going to catch me
so indeed yeah yeah
so uh we've gotten pretty active
um we were the first
entity ever invited by the National
League
to accompany them on a delegation to
Southeast Asia which was 2017 2017.
went to Bangkok
uh
Laos Cambodia and Hanoi never dreamed
I'd go to Hanoi yeah
um
we received the national league of
powmia families award they give an
annual award we got that
and so uh yeah we're doing pretty good
well we got back the tape up just a
little bit here Mr modesty because
uh one of the most dreaded elements of
running SOG Recon particularly in
Prairie Fire in the early years uh was
the dreaded NVA sappers
they surfaced several times in August
23rd killed 16 Green Berets that F would
be four uh Recon teams were hit and they
would go in and kill the Americans and
in fact they got a kill an American
award
and they would get they would be a
national hero in North Vietnam with the
commies
so they formed up
over time kept growing in size NBA
sapper SOG hunter killer teams
and later we learned right prior to you
going
that one of those units was called
simply c75
and during your trip there at some point
you representing that committee
met actual men who at one point were out
there their job was to hunt you and me
down to kill our ass
and you sir went in had a meeting with
them and it was part of a diplomatic
effort to enhance
our government's ability
to work fine locate identify and
hopefully someday bring home more of the
remains because as of today as we speak
1584 Americans are still listed as M.I.A
and Ann will chew me out for not saying
it the right way but throughout
southeast Asia and Thailand Vietnam
both North and South Laos Cambodia and a
couple in China
and you sir met with those men and that
really was a major Moment In Time
what was it like just sitting across
from those folks
and then meeting them of course you're
talking through an interpreter most of
the time I assume 100
and it did have some results and I know
later uh Kelly mccague who's the DPA
whatever his title is a director had uh
said that that meeting had impacts
positive so please a little bit more
there there is what was that like
there is an agency
part of the defense intelligence agency
called Stony Beach indeed and they are
the single U.S government agency
tasked with Gathering Intelligence on
are missing from the Vietnam War
there's lots in there from day one
during the war itself forever yes
these guys live over there
they speak language like the natives
they are trained in what they call
Strategic debriefing
they go all over the country
not interrogating interviewing uh
villagers following leads
they go to reunions of NVA units
divisions whatever
they go to museums
and look at all the artifacts and
displays and everything read newspapers
these guys are absolutely amazing
and then the defense powmia accounting
agency has people doing something
similar to that
and so these two groups of U.S
government people they found out about
c75
and they've been looking for all the
sapper units but they clearly identified
c75 so they went to
the Vietnamese counterpart to dpaa is
called the Vietnamese office for seeking
missing persons
and the director of that office set up
our meeting
and he had a company Commander a platoon
leader a squad leader and a soldier
really from c75 so it's interesting to
hear the perspectives from all those
different levels of command they would
not admit to being SOG a hunter killer
teams they said their mission was to
defend the trail against anyone who
would approach and threaten the trail
well do you know of anyone else
approaching and threatening the trail
except shock
they chuckled when I yeah yeah asked
that
I found some interesting things I always
thought that they had LZ Watchers
Elsie is a landing Zone where a team
could set their helicopter down or repel
or something
and I thought my God how many people
must they have to watch every LZ out
there
they had something like our forest fire
spotting Towers
they would build bamboo platforms up in
tall trees on high terrain that could
see a lot of elsies
and they had comms back to c75
headquarters and they said a team is
going in
they're going into an area we don't give
a hoot about and they would maybe leave
that team alone
but if we were going somewhere which was
usual
to find a pipeline or tapa comma wire or
something then they would send us out
send their people out to get us
I asked him about dogs which we know
they use they claim no they didn't use
dog there were some dogs in the area
that were used for hunting they said
indeed yeah uh
I I'm trying to remember I couldn't find
my copy of that report I need to get a
copy from you you said you still have my
trip report oh I could go uh we'll talk
about that you can send it later yeah I
can't believe I can't find that but many
interesting Lessons Learned and how I I
took a
when I was at CCs my team had killed a
NBA
Como signals officer I guess lieutenant
and I had his two red tabs of his branch
and his rank so I put those in a shadow
box with uh SOA coin and SFA coin and so
I gave that to the company Commander
they really appreciated it they said
there was good humor throughout the
whole thing
I've gotten some small amount of
feedback from members who didn't like me
consorting with the Enemy
but I tell them the same thing I told
the Laotian veterans organization I met
and c75 and vnosmp
[Music]
you know during war
it's not personal
you're out there because your government
sent you out there and you're trying to
protect your own life but you're trying
to accomplish a military Mission you've
assigned indeed
and we have to admire and respect
the enemy that's doing the same thing
and I did during the war a tenacious
enemy you had to yeah
um now admittedly I didn't work in areas
where the Viet Cong were murdering whole
Villages of men I didn't see atrocities
I saw armed units maneuvering against
each other
and I said once the war is over
that goes away
that enmity which is not personal to
begin with right and we admire and
respect
what you guys did
and we also have empathy for the people
you lost and the people still missing
and that's why I'm here is to
communicate with you about we're trying
to find our missing and so if there's
anybody has any information could you
please give it to these guys they had
dpaa and uh
Stoney beach in the in the meeting
then the thing that people really didn't
like because I put some pictures in the
after Action Report
Colonel High who's a wonderful man and
commands their office for seeking
missing persons
took us out for lunch it was
unbelievable
a big barbecued prawns and just good
food and we're all sitting around
laughing and so they brought out the
rice whiskey thank God it was lower
proof content and we must have 50 toast
I'm glad you didn't die I'm glad I
didn't kill you you know really yeah
yeah no it's good humor yeah you know it
was
a very positive experience for me and I
think for the US government
absolutely I mean Kelly mccague has said
that that effort
was um positive and that today now that
after the uh covert virus that stopped
all operations last year now they're
kicking them back into gear again
question to be how many but at least
they're doing it and at this point in
time
everyone who's familiar with this issue
for the last 50 years says that
um the Vietnamese and the Communists are
working and cooperating more with the US
than any time in history
um and during the covet shutdown of the
joint field activities U.S led
the Vietnamese continued to have field
activities and they found remains of our
people I didn't know that yeah no
identifications and I say our people
sure it could be
camel bones I don't know but they found
remains
in our absence out looking to help us
sure yeah oh no kidding yeah
wow
well we're at that point in time sir
we're kind of closing coming to the
closing Roundup here
um any any final thoughts from your days
your time
uh of course you grew up as a military
brat traveling with your dad and you
said I'm never going to join the
military no way as it turns out
but you know what when I was in college
I don't know what I was thinking I just
took courses I was interested in they
didn't prepare me to do any career what
the heck you know so I had to take two
years of ROTC it was mandatory and I
said that's the end of it that's the
last but then Vietnam was really heating
up sure and I knew the difference in a
01 and an E1 so I took two more years of
ROTC right and I came in and I hated the
mech infantry yeah I never would have
been there past my uh three-year
commitment but when I got to SF
I was home indeed because of the people
oh yeah you said any final thoughts yes
please thank God for the people
that I met and served with amen our
final salute tomorrow yeah and of course
we mentioned Jim Butler earlier he just
passed away a couple days ago yeah it's
just a sad sad note a Fearless Recon man
with the
served at least two tours of Duty and
SOG ran some incredible missions and was
our leader with the SOA
um so last wrap up thought before we go
into our final closing sir thank you for
what you're doing to keep the history
alive your books are terrific and you've
inspired Dave Maurer and Nick
brockhausen and uh
just fabulous authors never knew you
guys had it in you
I'm going to have to report you for
keeping notes uh that we were not
allowed to keep
but thank you Tim another pleasure we're
honored to have you today thanks for
taking the time to come out yes sir and
this uh we want to thank to all our
veterans out there men like Mike who
have fought for the ideals of our
country truly you sir are an American
hero in our eyes and to those of you out
there on the front lines today
we thank you for fighting all for our
our deals today under most difficult
circumstances we also thank as always
all of our military army navy Marine
Corps Air Force Coast Guard and yes the
space force now
and we also thank the police law
enforcement border patrol
the Secret Service dispatchers
paramedics folks that are out there
and last but not least an issue that is
close to our hearts of every sock man
for those who didn't come home
a virus loot to you and we thank you for
your service
until next time
so we're we're back for our post
interview
um summary review of the yet another
very deep and personal interview we want
to thank Mike Taylor for coming out
today
and so
Tom a top secret man here we can't
reveal your identity but what was your
impression For the First Time The Sea
and hear Mike's stories and of course
another insight into the sog from a
different perspective yes I always
wondered what it was like to be that
that Covey Rider or nail Rider
um that fake a right excuse me but you
know altitude looking over and you know
it's really
insightful
um as to what it looks like from
altitude looking down
and what goes into it
um you know the different platforms that
they flew on are in and you know just
the courage that they took as well I
mean being up there because you're
completely exposed I mean there's no
it's like I can hide behind a tree yeah
no yeah and then the end vehicle coming
down with more of the anti-aircraft and
particularly back when they had the o2s
I mean there was just slow movers right
and for us on the ground it was critical
to have the Como they would come out you
see them flying around
and it's like oh what took you so long
to get here being critical as opposed to
hey thanks you're here yeah let's get on
with the story well of course you're on
the ground
I mean you're like please get here quick
please get her right but it's uh but
when they got there they brought their
friends with him and then when they and
then when they switched the attends
right oh 10 and now they have the
capability not just to hey you know come
over here and shoot there but now they
can inflict damage and thanks to Mike
Taylor for that oh yeah bringing that in
you know and and being the you know
spearheading that and and bringing it
forward and bringing that out
um because I I'm sure for you guys that
it's on the ground wolf was like this is
awesome day and night because you know
during my 19 months it wasn't until like
month 17 that we had the first time with
an ov10 actually come in with rockets
and I forget I don't know if he had the
he but he still came in and made rocket
runs well
you know the o2s could barely get off
the ground with two men in him so what
was that like on the ground what was
that like the first time you're sitting
there on the ground you're obviously at
that point your troops in contact right
then yeah
and you see Kobe flying and you're like
okay good well now we know they're here
now I know airplanes are coming in and
all of a sudden he makes a gun run well
yeah well it was first it was he was
whoever this pilot was was really cool
he came up on the uh on the emergency
frequency
we linked up we're talking he and he
came by so we hit him with the mirror
connect quickly he goes where's your
closest threat
and I go give them the locations that
are South could we make contact going
downhill and came back to little plateau
and he goes okay I'm gonna make a gun
run or a a Rocket run I go say again
repeat I am I last transmission could
you repeat that one more time
um I've got a I got a Rocketeer
and so I'll make gun runs okay do it
let's do it here so we we made it like
game the coordinates to the point where
you go and Etc he came in and did it wow
and it was like whoa this is nice a nice
new tool in our toolbox I hope we always
get ov10s from here on so that's
probably like a current you know more of
a current time frame you think about
those guys uh A10 Pilots no yeah it's
the same thing I mean that's a you know
that was an SF guy in in a plane that's
helping coordinate between the two yeah
and a 10 Pilots you're you know uh
talking with some of them it's like
they're like the Infantry of the air
they're the guys that understand the
battle space they understand the ground
and they do such a wonderful job you
know they save so many lives they're
like the modern day version of the A1
yeah the 20 airplane that was built
around a weapon system
literally just built around the gun like
here's your gun build the plane yeah now
go kill bad guys they're trying to kill
our people yeah imagine if you had had
that back then oh I mean imagine I mean
you think about that now and it's like
wow I wish we'd had some of this stuff
but well you know when a spad made a gun
run with 450 calibers roaring out yeah
or the 20 mic mics yeah it's pretty
impressive it's got your and like Mike
said those a1s could just stay on
station yeah make gun run after gun run
bombing runs then come down with some
CBU of course
my favorite is crispy Critter time yeah
whenever it comes out with the Napalm
Napalm yeah oh my God I can't use that
anymore but not
it's still out there
um one thing I'll say is this you know
there's not a whole lot of officers that
typically gain a lot of respect from
enlisted there's you know it's typically
kind of one of those things where it's
officer enlisted separation yes and it's
it's
really hard for enlisted guys to have
respect for people that don't do what
you do as an enlisted guy but right back
then things were different you know uh
Mike is one of those dick Thompson's
another one oh you know I mean the
people he went through like Gary Rob
Gary Rob yeah he ran all in ditch by
himself and you look at those guys and
that to me is what they need to take
back in these ROTC the academy these are
the guys they need to show the
leadership how to be leaders because
that's leading you know that's that's
true leading whether that's a an NCO or
a an officer that's leading you're you
lead from the front you don't lead from
a desk yeah our higher headquarters are
and the command and control helicopter
that's five clicks away and putting
himself in for DFCS I'll say she's
pretty courageous because he uh he
doesn't mind saying his opinion to those
above them some of us also have a issue
with that but it's a yeah it's always
it's a breath of fresh air to see
someone that was doing that back then
too you know like that that still that
was still like you had people that were
this isn't right no I'm not doing that
I'm not going to risk my my life or the
lives of those around me because you
want me to do something that makes no
tactical sense and it's good to see that
there's a lot of those leaders that are
out there that have that good tactical
sense to say that's not smart you're not
here you're at a desk oh yeah
so oh yeah great stories I mean
phenomenal
um he wears it you know like a I was
saying in between like he wears it on
his sleeve and most of you guys do and
rightfully so because it's not just a
pilot as he said it's not just a pilot
that went down oh no that's a person and
it's someone he knew you know it's names
it's that's that's what people don't get
they just read a book or something
they're like oh pilot went down okay
yeah because when you're in Stateside
military there's the inter-service
rivalries that go on yeah which is all
part of the fun and games and sometimes
you rub some fist fights but once you're
across the fence it's US versus them and
our hearts went out to those guys that
supported us yeah and uh yeah sometimes
with horrific losses and uh Mike covers
some of those today with a really a
deeper Insight than we've had anything
with our first eight podcast yeah and
then his work with you know the pows and
and going back over there with DPA and
trying to oh yeah to this day you know I
don't know if I could have done it
that's that's amazing and you know if
there's ever a time that I could help
out with that I definitely would it's
it's one of those organizations that you
look at this and there's you know you
think about it from people here it's
like hey there's uh you know a missing
child and your heart goes out to him but
it's like hey these These are these are
children too you know they were
someone's children and their parents
never got to see them again or their
brothers never get to see them or their
sisters or their spouse and it's like
they're still there let's find them
let's bring them up like with Robin on
that's my personal case where he's a 1-1
on Idaho that disappears still amongst
the 50 and and when he left his dike
across the country
sent the money home to his wife and said
I'll be back he left May 1st and 20 days
later he's M.I.A yeah because he didn't
have to so it's one of many names yeah
so anyways any other last thoughts there
and uh if not no we will close we thank
Jocko willink productions for making
these possible for helping us to bring
together people to talk about more of
Our Song history as time goes on and yes
we still salute all of our service
members the first line people that are
online today from our secret servers
border patrol every agency is out there
defending our country we thank you all
today
till next time